It's great to welcome to the program today.
EJJ Deon, who is a columnist for the Washington
post senior fellow at the Brookings institution
and also author of code red, how progressives
and moderates can unite to save our country.
So I guess the first question is unite to
save the country from who or what. Right.
Right. And, uh, in the first instance, it's
obviously Trump, Trump ism the attack on the
rule of law that we've been seeing a lot very
recently, but all through, uh, the administration
to turn away from democracy, but it's also
to save the country from a radicalized right
and radicalized Republican party. Um, the
book is obviously a very anti Trump book,
uh, but it is also very critical of a radical
right that really now dominates the Republican
party and is driven out all vestiges of, uh,
both moderation. And back in the day, even
some liberalism, uh, progressivism that existed
inside the Republican party. And so I already
knew that in this circumstance, uh, Progressive's
and moderates, and we can argue about the
term moderate, I'm, I'm careful in the book
to say, I know moderate itself is a vexed
term, but we couldn't say the center left
and the left, uh, as well, that they have
far more in common each other at this moment.
Uh, then, uh, they, um, then they have with
anyone on the other side, their differences
are much smaller than there are differences
of where the other side and a subsidiary argument
is that one of the reasons arguments inside
the democratic party can get so fierce is
that, um, people who are on the progressive
side have lost a sort of sensible interlocutor
in the Republican party that almost all the
major conversations about solving public problems
take place inside the democratic party. So
Obamacare was a program that was built in
part on ideas developed by the heritage foundation
and by Mitt Romney in Massachusetts. And this
was cast as somehow socialist by the other
side. And so Democrats are now having the
argument that might in another era have taken
place across party lines. You expand on Obamacare
or do you go to single payer? That's the kind
of argument I make in the book, but I argue
to get past this, uh, moment, both of the
Trump moment and of a radicalized conservatism,
Progressive's and moderates need to be allied
because that's the only way out of this, um,
this morass we're in.
So does that presume this idea of vote for
the democratic nominee no matter who they
are? Like is that a related idea to what you
are arguing?
Right. I think in this circumstance there
is pretty much no alternative to that and
it's obvious that there are, you know, a lot
of Democrats, especially after last night,
um, who might have second thoughts about voting
for Michael Bloomberg be my exact question
because, um, you know, and I think that, that,
that will be, um, more difficult. I mean,
I think it was difficult going into that debate.
I think it's even more difficult coming out
of that debate. Similarly, there are people
on the right end, if you will, of this broad
coalition I'm describing who have some questions
about Bernie Sanders at this moment. Um, uh,
I think that Bloomberg question will be the
harder question for an awful lot of people,
both on the left. Uh, and, um, you know, after
the demolition job that, uh, Elizabeth Warren
did, particularly among progressive women.
Yeah. And, uh, you know, I've said I'm not
supporting Bloomberg in the primary, but if
it's November 3rd, and it's Bloomberg versus
Trump, I'm voting for Bloomberg. And I've
pointed out, I think on Supreme court justice
selections, Bloomberg will make far better
choices than what Trump has evidenced. He
would do. I've listed a few things and it
doesn't mean I'm any great fan of him, but
I know a lot of people in my audience don't
feel that way at all. And my, my sort of follow
on question to this is I believe in and support
what we would a vigorous debate during the
primary about which ideas should reign Supreme,
so to speak. But I wonder is there a point
at which it becomes self-destructive in the
eventual general election?
Yeah, I am worried about that. I, I, you may
have noticed, I have a column up today, uh,
where, uh, and this was a, I wrote most of
it before the debate. Um, that the kind of,
uh, demolition Derby that Democrats are having,
um, is leading to, they're ignoring right
on that stage last night, what is going on
outside. It was really striking how little
Trump himself was mentioned. We are really
at a potential constitutional crisis here
with what's going on inside the justice department.
What has gone on with Roger Stone, how all
these cases are being cherry picked, uh, on
Ukraine and Russia by, uh, by bar. These are
very disturbing things. It did disturb me
that Democrats were spending so much time,
um, sort of settling their own differences
that they didn't even get to. Um, Hey, we're
all here because we need to put a stop to
this.
You know, on your lumber point. I think you're
correct that on court appointments, on what
his budgets would look like, even his tax
program is far more progressive than anything.
Um, Republicans had to offer. And his support
for both the climate movements and especially
the gun movements is a real thing. He's made
a huge difference there. Um, I think that
what we saw last night will raise questions
not only on the left, but a lot of other people
saying, is this ag, is he actually the strongest
candidate to put against Trump? I think that
was the argument he needed to make. And clearly
last night on that prompt was a fail.
No, certainly if, if his making billions dependent
on winning debates, I don't know that he would
be nearly nearly as wealthy as a, as he is
was, was my reaction. Yeah. So now in terms
of when we've seen in the past elections that
are heavily based around defeating the incumbent,
so John Kerry in 2004 against George W. Bush
strikes me as one of those. Um, there is often
the argument made that you've really gotta
be voting for something as opposed to trying
to remove the incumbent that it often doesn't
go well when the main message is removed,
the incumbent. So do you agree with that and
is that maybe something that tempers the problem
of, of Trump not being mentioned that much
yesterday? Which in a way I found refreshing
to just hear the candidates talk about something
other than Trump.
Well, I think there are two sides to this
and maybe we can take Ronald Reagan as the
example. One of my arguments in the book by
the way, is that w uh, uh, a key reason why
there has a resurgence of democratic socialism
in the U S which by the way has a long American
tradition. As I point out in the book, Eugene
Debs got 6% of the boat. There were actually
1200 local elected officials who were socialists
back in that election. Um, the reason why
you've had a revival of a democratic socialism
is a reaction to the dominance of our public
conversation, um, by the Reagan economic consensus.
And so the rise of democratic socialism is,
uh, a reaction against that. But what did
Reagan do to create that long, had Gemini
that long a period of conservative dominance?
I think there were two sides of it. I think
running against an incumbent who's unpopular,
uh, is actually a helpful thing.
Politically. Jimmy Carter was unpopular and
I argue in the book for what I call the power
of negative thinking. Uh, that when you looked
at what Ronald Reagan built his program on,
it started out as a series of negatives. Anti-tax
uh, anticommunist anti-government, I think
what posts together this coalition are a similar
set of antis obviously anti-Trump and all
the things that represents, uh, Yohei the
oppression of immigrants and refugees, a,
you know, corporate corruption cast as populism.
Um, a whole disrespect for women, a whole
series of, uh, things. Um, but also a backlash
against, um, a Republican party that is simply
given up on public problem solving, on using
government, uh, to redress inequality, uh,
to provide health insurance a whole series
of areas where they propose simply retreating,
cutting taxes, relying entirely on the public
sector. But out of that negative comes a series
of positives.
And if I can just pick three quick issues
that are really burning issues that raise
real coalition building possibilities. Um,
right now the entire democratic party, the
entire spectrum from center to left now wants
to provide affordable, good health insurance
to every American. That's not even debated
anymore. The debate is over whether we do
it through a public option in building on
Obamacare or go directly up to single pair.
Lord, I do not think we should divide ourselves
radically over the path. We can disagree,
we can debate the path, but we all want to
go broadly in the same direction. AOC underscored
that recently, um, with her comments. A second
one is free college. That's not so radical.
We used to have it before the massive underinvestment
in public education. Whether we get there
in one step or many steps and let's make sure
this includes not only college of, but also
training for people who don't want to go to
college.
I'm in the book, I quote Richard Cordray ran
for governor of Ohio. Unfortunately he didn't
win, but I love this line. He said, you shouldn't
have to go to college to join the middle-class.
I think we need to broaden that conversation,
but that's got a lot of possibility. And lastly,
the green new deal, which when you boil the
green new deal down, it is saying that we
need urgently to act on the climate and we
also urgently need to restructure the economy
to make it fairer. Uh, and we need to do that
partly to redress losses that some groups
might suffer from taking bold action on the
climate. I think these are all positives that
grow out of all of those negatives. So I guess
I am not worried that a pure anti Trump campaign
will lack a positive vision. Uh, because I
think you're hearing a lot of positives in
all these, in the mess of all these debates,
there were actually a lot of proposals. Well,
book a, I want to make clear is not proposing
this vague idea of unity for the sake of unity.
The way that we've seen, uh, criticized over
the last couple of months as we've seen the
democratic primary shift. It's really a practical
and a sensible perspective on what it is simply
that needs to happen. The book is by EJD on,
it is called code red. How Progressive's and
moderates can unite to save our [inaudible]
country. MJ, so great having you on. I appreciate
your time. Thank you so much. I hope we can
do this again.